good morning it's Thursday unfortunately
I have to deliver some bad news to an
old friend today good morning bust of
Edgar Allan Poe you look great I mean 14
years after I won you for my novel Paper
Towns I think you look better than ever
there's just one problem bust of Edgar
Allan Poe you are now my second favorite
pistachio bust that's right Edgar
there's a new bust in town and boy is he
phenomenal anyway Hank as you pointed
out in your video yesterday Simple
Solutions to complex problems are almost
always inadequate we all want to be like
one flipped switch away from a better
life or a better world but life doesn't
work that way except I think there is
one thing in this broken world that is
truly and unambiguously good and holy a
Guiding Light that never goes out and
that is committing to the bit bit
commitment Hank is so beautiful and I
know it can't solve all of our problems
but it can bring us joy when I refer to
bit commitment I'm thinking for instance
instance of the YouTuber Jonathan Mann
who has written recorded and released a
song every day for the last five
thousand nineteen days I just find it so
lovely because the quality of bit
commitment is astonishing I feel the
same way albeit on a much smaller scale
about our ridiculous decision to use
every word from the lyrics of All-Star
as video titles it was so stupid
literally the only good thing about that
idea was that it required us to really
commit to the bit which in the end I
think made it kind of beautiful here's
another example once when I was in
college I was eating dinner at a diner
with a friend in Mount Vernon Ohio and I
was talking about how I'd always wanted
to see Elvis's home of Graceland and she
was like we should go and I said yeah
and she was like no we should go right
now and then we paid the bill and drove
11 hours directly to Graceland which you
know was okay it turns out Elvis and I
have somewhat different taste in
interior design but I remember the trip
fondly not because of Graceland but
because we committed to the bit like if
we'd gone back to the dorms and gotten
our toothbrushes and changes of clothes
it would have totally ruined it but
because we went straight from the diner
to Graceland it's a treasured memory
when I think of bit commitment I think
of Dolly Smith who for 70 years didn't
miss a single match of her beloved Darby
County football club I think of Marina
Abramovich and her partner Ule agreeing
to meet in the middle of the Great Wall
of China and then each walking over 2
000 kilometers to reach each other and I
think of the Reddit user who in 2012
wrote your mama's so lazy and then
returned in 2021 to write she took nine
years to finish this joke anyway I
mentioned all this for two reasons Hank
first to point out how utterly
completely profoundly committed to the
bit you must be in order to purchase
this pizza John floor rug I mean look at
it it's incredible no one will ever
question your level of bit Commitment if
this is on your floor I don't know how
other people are going to use their
Pizza John for rugs but I'll tell you
how I use mine I keep putting it in
different rooms of the house and then I
wait for Sarah to come in and be like oh
right but that's not the point of the
video the point of the video Hank is
that secondly I think you and I need to
have a hard look in the mirror and ask
ourselves are we doing everything we can
to commit to existing bits and to
discover new bits which we might commit
to when I think of bit commitment I
often think of a listener to Dear Hank
and John who wrote a few years back to
say that they were going to secretly
learn how to play the fiddle and then
surprise their family with a fiddle
concert now I don't know if they ever
actually did this but enough time has
passed between when the question was
asked and now that they could have
provided they adequately committed to
the bit and that's a reminder to me Hank
that as the ancient proverb puts it the
best time to commit to a bit was 20
years ago the second best time is today
Hank I'll see you tomorrow